I would imagine though that you get
emails every day from people who are
asking for career advice can you tell
from some of the emails those who really
want help and those you may not be able
to help yes there are people who somehow
I think something's gonna be given to
them and there are other people who
reach out to you for guidance of how
they can get it themselves the people
who ask for guidance of how they can get
it for themselves I'm interested in them
because they're not asking me to do it
for them they're saying you've had
experience and I'm willing to listen to
you so I don't make crazy mistakes and
so those people like you're late to
because somebody did that for me
but people who come out and they just
want as you so eloquently spoke before
it but if not a variety they're not
serious about this industry not serious
about being a great actor or a great
writer and great producer a great
director they just want to be seen and
that people know who they are I don't
take them seriously and
our foundation it's called the media
foundation and you teach kids media
literacy which I thought what are the
jobs of the future gonna be in financial
literacy if you make money how do you
not just spend it and use it and so kids
because the young kids that are serious
we can get an opportunity to help them
we do I think there's a validity in
coming out here with dreams and one used
to be I guess recognized and writing but
that's not a serious craft or industry
that's just some of the securities you
have that you want overcome so when you
receive an email how can you tell the
ones that really are looking to find
ways how they can then do it themselves
and those who just want sort of a hand
up they say it they're very clear I mean
um there's some people who are so
unaware of how this place works they'll
say like um oh I want to agent and I
know you have an agent can solution to
your agent I'm saying give any pictures
I don't have any pictures okay give it
real no I don't have a real have you
ever acted in a home or a play nobody
have an acting teacher and and people
think I'm a handsome they really think
I'm beautiful and they have my taking
them they think I'm talented
what do you say to that I mean I I
thought okay I God knows I wish you luck
but you're coming out here with nothing
you want me to just drive you my agent
it doesn't work that way then our kids
they have pictures resume Dex if they
have a project the Ducks for their
project pictures actors attached they
didn't the research for the demographic
of what they're trying to sell to the
return on your investment how much money
it now when I see that whoa
come here let's talk because you're
serious
III can still I can teach you but you
don't need that much teaching what you
need is opportunity it's just a
different experience
I'm just looking for I want to meet your
agents I don't be mean but I just can't
I can't do that agent says to me why did
you bring that person here they wanted
to meet you
that's not good
you